alors bien sûr se poser la question sur
la force des ventes changera guère la
physionomie des paysages désormais
détruit
il n'empêche les questions viennent sur
les prévisions de météo france sur le
mélange d'ouragan de tornades constaté
de l'ouest à l'est de la france enquête
sur un phénomène météorologique complexe
qu'à nice monteux laetitia loge en brie
christophe laroque
une tempête d'une tête violents sur une
distance aussi grande en france
les météorologues n'avais encore jamais
vu ça ce qui frappe le plus les
scientifiques c'est que la force des
vents n'a pas diminué en s'enfonçant à
l'intérieur des terres bien au contraire
à 4 heures du matin et hier des rafales
de 184 kilomètres heure frappe l'île
d'ouessant 180 km/heure dans le calvados
173 km heure à orly en ile de france et
144 kilomètres heure à strasbourg mais
plus à l'est
les gens deviennent encore plus violent
de 100 kilomètres heure en suisse et 213
km heure dans la forêt noire en
allemagne
cette dépression très creuse s'est
déplacé rapidement
elle s'apparente un cyclone
ce n'est pas ainsi qu'on tropicales on
est loin des tropiques mais c'est un
cyclone dans le sens que le sens de la
circulation générale des vents c'est
dans le sens contraire aux aiguilles
d'une montre
météo france avait été très précis sur
la trajectoire de ce cyclone mais
impossible de prévoir les mini
tourbillon à l'intérieur même de la
dépression qui ont localement accentuer
l'effet tempête nous avions sous-estimé
la force des vents un peu sous-estimé la
force des vents eh bien ça s'explique en
effet par ces phénomènes locaux qui
naissent et qui disparaissent dans une
période de temps extrêmement réduite
pour comprendre ces mini tourbillon il
faut remonter à 8000 mètres d'altitude
jusque dans la tropopause la des vents
violents de 400 km heure se serait
rabattu sur le sol un phénomène très
rare qui expliquerait l'intensité de
cette tempête en pleine terre